hello everyone and welcome to round 11
of the 2018 Tata Steel chess tournament
already ten rounds have passed and how -
only managed to score four draws so she
lost six games and he or she faces a
former world champion Vishwanathan Anand
having the black pieces so now not an
easy task and although she's not having
the greatest tournament in our life look
at for example Fabiana Corwin eye after
ten rounds he only managed to achieve
four points so if you look at Carson
Geary and mommy Jericho who are already
at seven points that's not quite quite
an achievement as Khurana is a member of
the 2800 Club with a rating of twenty
eight hundred and eleven points so four
draws in six losses doesn't seem that
bad when a player of kiwanis caliber has
only four points so let's see this game
and how will she fare against former
world champion Anand has the white
pieces and he opens the game with c4 the
English opening we have II 6/9 to c3 and
c5 another place d4 transposes into the
Queen's Gambit the client and we have
Knight to f6 seek after sandy five
Knight captures on d5 and the immediate
efore knife captor zombie uncie 3d
captures on c3 and c5 by even and here
there are a couple of options for Anand
you can go on out of three Bishop d3 for
example but should be five check maybe
Allen goes for rook to b1 and the reason
he was for rook to be one even will
probably play b6 and develop the bishop
on b7 but nevertheless it it exerts
certain pressure on the b7 pawn and also
you want to see how your opponent will
develop his pieces and only then will
you decide what are the best squares for
your for your own pieces so rugby one
might you know may or may not be the
better move here instead of maybe
developing tonight or the bishop but it
will you know it will make your opponent
to think about what's what and it will
you know pressure him so definitely
definitely an interesting move and
definitely what differentiates a great
player from an amazing player so Bishop
to e7 and now
was for Knight to f3 we have castles and
Bishop to c4 Bishop to d3 is also also a
good move but Anand has some ideas of
pushing b5 in the future so the bishop
on c4 will add more pressure to the d5
square we have Knight to c6
Anand castles and b6 now Bishop to e3
Bishop to b7 and Queen to e to see
capture son b4 seek after son before and
the crook to c8 another develops is that
a rook rook after d1 and what this move
Anand has finished developing all of his
pieces and now it's time to find a plan
we have Queen to c7 and here it comes
here are not plays d5 and what do you do
here
the even play Knight to e5 but also an
interesting move might be Knight to a5
not allowing any exchanges in the center
but here after Bishop to b5 and here we
can do one exchange that tonight isn't
looking very useful on a5 so instead
after d5 even goes from Knight to e5
again we have Bishop to b5 e capture
some v5 e captures on d5 and here you
found exchanges that night Knight
capture screen captures and we have
Bishop to c5 offering more exchanges
here Anand pins the Bishop rook beat the
c1 and Queen to e7 unpinning and Bishop
to f4 again honored doesn't allow the
trade of bishops and is preparing the
move d6 we have Bishop to d6 again even
offers the exchange of bishops and stops
at the pond from being pushed forward
and here aren't placed Bishop to c6
he doesn't allowed the rooks to be
traded and if he even will capture the
bishop then he will already have his
passed pawn on the 6th rank and here you
probably want to play something like
rook C to d8
if if aren't exchanges then you can
capture with the rook and then the other
group can be placed to d8 and already
you have double the rocks on the D file
sorry but - actually goes for the
immediate exchange Bishop captures on f4
we have Queen captures on f4 and
your captors and c6 Bond characters and
c6 and here Queen even goes for Queen to
c7 offering an exchange of Queens and if
you exchange Queens here Queen captures
rook captures you don't have a passport
on the sixth rank but you can never push
it any further the other rook will come
to see it and you can't hope for
anything with white here if anything
black black black might be the one that
has chances here as this pawn will be
lost at some point or or it won't be
lost but you know neither side that will
be able to make any progress
so after Queen to c7 Islands plays rook
to d6 avoiding the trade of Queens and
also now this rook is also protecting
the c6 pawns
so I useful move however you look at it
Roxy to d8 here offering an exchange of
another of rook and now Roxy to d1
doubling up on the D file we have h6
even makes some breathing room for
further King and g3 Aaron plays g3 just
for protecting his Queen so now the rook
on d6 can move maybe even capture
something so if it's not what to check
you will not lose his Queen rock after
some d6 look after some v6 and rook the
c8 and here the past poni and the 6th
rank is very dangerous when the Queen's
are on the board so and will never
exchange Queens here and he plays Queen
to e5 and it's a very dangerous position
you can't really improve with black so
probably best thing you could do is
maybe play rook to d8 and have to route
to d8 for example rook captures Queen
captures push c7 the Queen will have to
go to d7 and now Queen the c3 preparing
to point to c8
this Queen will have to block it and now
after the queen is on c8 White has a
much better position here and he will
probably win this game it's very hard to
say if black could hold this so this
would probably be the best idea for even
although it's very passive but after
this Queen to e5 move if and decided to
play b5 what's the idea behind b5
have no idea of course it can be
captured since the rope would be hanging
on d6 maybe maybe to start pushing her
own pawns on the Queen side but the b5
move is actually a pretty pretty big
wonder as he Ronon plays Queen to d5 and
here he has a terrible threat of playing
rook to d7 so if the black Queen
captures on c6 Anand will capture on f7
and deliver checkmate there's really
really nothing black can play here if
you try something like a six let's say
then then it's just the same rope to d7
Queen captures Queen captures f7 this
will lead to checkmate any other move
you can play maybe Queen to e7 if Queen
to e7 then rub the d7 again and there is
really nothing you can do here you have
to move the Queen now comes Queen
captures and after the King moves c7
let's say you can give a couple of
checks check here but after King to h3
it's really it's really over Queen here
you will avoid the trade of course here
you can offer trade again but now rook
captures for example on g7 and this is
just one line but every line favors
whitey
now if captured with the King of course
Queen d7 picks up the rook if you
capture with the Queen then Queen to f5
check will capture the rook and c8 so
after this King the Queen to d5 move
King to h7 was tried but now comes Queen
to e4 check King to g8 and now rook to
d7 and here you can't capture the pawn
on c6 once again even though the queen
is on e4 because if you capture it then
comes rook to d8 check and the Queen is
covering the h7 squares so the King has
nowhere to go you have to capture the
rook and then Queen captures Queen you
lose the Queen and the game
so after this rook to d7 even cried
Queen to a5 but now simply c7 and it's
it's all over it's really there's really
nothing you can do if you try something
like B for you're gonna get
Queen to f4 and there is no defense
against Queen captures f7 if you try to
defend this with
rook to f8 then you will get to rope to
d8 so they're very very hard position
for black whatever if Anna would play
here it's it's lost after c7 even try to
rook to f8 and here after Queen to e7
she resigned the game as there are
simply too many threats the most obvious
is Queen captures rook you have to king
recaptures and rook will deliver check
and then this pawn will be promoted but
anything you play loses the game
instantly so yeah this is round 11
not not the best game for even although
it was pretty close you know maybe she
could hold this with the line eyes I
shown you instead of pushing this pawn
to b5 but we will never know it's hard
to say I mean III don't think she could
hold that position against Anna but it
would definitely be better than this b5
idea so yeah two more rounds to go until
the end of the Tata Steel chess
tournament while I was making this video
I saw that Geary drew his game and
Carlson drew his game against my media
off so all three of them are now on
seven and a half points sharing first
place and Anand after winning this game
again Stephen is now on seven points
only half point behind the leaders and
one interesting thing giri said after
drawing his game against Fabiano Caruana
was that if there will be a tiebreaker
at the end of the tournament that most
likely Magnus Carlsen will win it as
like Geary said cross and didn't lose a
tie-break since some tournament in 2006
so very interesting but we'll have to
wait two more days to see what happens
so that's the game I will try and check
out are there any more in more
interesting games from the Tata Steel if
not maybe I will cover one game from the
Gibraltar chess tournament as so the
didn't have any time to cover that
tournament as they decided to you know
have two tournaments two big tournaments
simultaneously which is you know not
cool but on the other hand it's great
that there are so many chest events that
they are overlapping now so yeah I would
like to thank Andrew Connick I didn't
automatically
is niala Douglas Perry Oliver Todd love
and Morgan Gillard for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it and I would like to thank
everyone for your help in translations
of my videos whether it's the title the
description or simply adding subtitles
so thank you very much
yesterday I checked if there were any
since I don't get notifications for such
things and there were like 60 60
translations so thank you very much for
that as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here if you haven't
checked out the subscribers video there
will be a link in the description below
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon